this morning as you see we're coming to
you from our homes out of caution over
this coronavirus outbreak President
Trump says following social distancing
guidelines is quote a matter of life and
death and we are getting that message he
spoke yesterday as a White House made a
grim prediction that up to 240,000
Americans will die during this pandemic
officials expect major spikes in the
death toll during the next two weeks
Tony good goodness that is news nobody
wants to hear and that's why it is so
important to follow the rules yeah
that's that's right Gail and of course
this is a health crisis but it's also an
economic crisis and today is the first
of the month and that means bills are
often due millions of Americans now
suddenly trying to make a decision how
are they gonna pay them should they pay
them remind you that the Federal Reserve
Bank of st. Louis a federal economist
estimated that 47 million Americans
could lose their jobs as companies
affected by the virus cut their staff
millions have already lost their job and
we visited one small business that had
to cut most of its workforce and we
spoke with people there on both sides of
that very painful decision you know I
mean I get it this has never happened
before
this never happened before gaben now
gets why his company let him go but when
we visited his house last week he still
hadn't figured out what to do about it
so April first are you gonna make a
mortgage payment or not good question we
haven't even talked about that at the
start of March just four weeks ago his
company corporate AV was scheduled to
handle lighting and sound for dozens of
events this spring Joe guild erson is
the owner before the virus actually
things were looking great we're a full
steam
we had to probably of the best months
we've ever had ever
yeah and we're on track for a full
spring season
then the pandemic and bans on large
gatherings every day go to work more
jobs are being taken off the board more
more jobs more jobs and then there was
like okay now there's a problem no it's
a serious problem those jobs represented
about $800,000 in revenue roughly 1/5 of
what Gill dersen expected to take in
this year it forced a question facing
business owners across the country with
no money coming in and cost piling up
how many people to layoff according to
research by JP Morgan Chase the typical
small business has less than a month of
cash reserves to survive a situation
like this
it was pretty gut-wrenching to be honest
not a lot of sleep night before knowing
what was gonna happen overnight
corporate a/v went from 20 employees to
6 what was it like to get the call from
Joe saying your position is not here
anymore
I wasn't was this press moe Johnson had
worked for the company for more than 20
years you got to do something and my
thing is do whatever you can to save the
company saves it ship will swim to shore
save the ship well we get back on the
ship we can go again but if the ships
not there you know that's the problem
what kind of severance package to people
get not much I be honest we had a week's
worth of income basically to provide him
I think everyone in the group really
said listen you got to keep this thing
afloat I need someplace to come back to
and you know on that I figure is my job
so you still have one more check or
direct deposit coming pretty much yeah
which was today actually so today yeah
that's it and now admits he's still
processing the immediate shock of losing
his job and his family's health
insurance his wife Claudia says they
were already living paycheck to paycheck
if you could get a meeting tomorrow with
leaders in Congress what would you want
them to know about what a family like
yours needs I think I would just ask
them for a better sense of stability
you're just constantly worried about
like
can I make this payment can I put my kid
you know can I get a doctor even before
even before and now it underscores how
important those things are absolutely
what kind of situation are you in in
terms of money in the bank
same as everybody I don't really have a
lot of money they'll get help from
unemployment insurance and the stimulus
package there may also be power in
numbers with so many businesses closed
and so many people idle there's hope
that out of work doesn't mean out of
luck
as a nation you know they can't say oh
these people would generates we kick
them out or take away this and take away
that there's gonna be some solace to its
side so I believe that they need to stop
the mortgage payments they need to stop
all the phone payments they need to stop
all that for a couple months at least 90
days or something to have people be on
their feet you know is it easier or
harder to deal with this knowing that
there's nothing you did personally to
cause it well I guess if there was a
moral ground then that would be a
victory but unfortunately it doesn't
really help right the second so when you
reflect on kind of what you've had to go
through in 14 or 15 years to kind of
build something up and and help all the
people you like to think you've helped
it's frustrating and that right there is
a microcosm of what millions of small
businesses are going through right now
Joe guilt Orson says he does hope to
hire back the entire staff eventually
but it could take a while to ramp things
up this was supposed to be their busiest
season and instead they're looking at
business not picking up perhaps until
the fall now Anthony I want to point out
that this really matters for all
Americans because most Americans in fact
work for what is defined as a small
business so it's also important to point
out that there is help so the federal
stimulus provided for up to ten million
dollars in loans as part of a paycheck
protection program for small businesses
and those loans are completely forgiven
if it's applied to payroll so small
businesses can find more information on
that online and the Treasury saying that
they will start approving and dispersing
that money
by this Friday but one of the big
variables is if you've already laid off
all your staff and now you're looking
into an uncertain future is it too late
already
yeah it's it's so difficult for any
small business to plan for for any
disruption but one like this which is
still open-ended we don't know when it's
gonna end oh it's impossible a lot of
people are gonna be going through this
all right Tony Thanks